British actress Josephine Melville has
died she was 61. the performer
reportedly died backstage at the
Nottingham playhouse in the UK after a
performance of the play nine at night
it's full of joy and comedy and it's
relatable it's unclear what exactly
happened to Josephine we do know
paramedics were backstage but she died
at the scene her cause of death is
currently unknown
the playhouse addressed the shocking
news on Twitter paying tribute with this
Josephine was a truly wonderful and
well-loved person a revered and deeply
respected performer director producer
archivist and writer we are offering our
full support to her family our onstage
and production crew and all staff at
this awful time as of now the theater
has canceled the remaining performances
of the show hello
my name is Josephine Melville
and I'm going to read a piece of poetry
for you from poetry to plays television
and film Josephine's career spanned 40
years you may write me down in history
with your bitter Twisted lies you may
trod me in the very Earth but still like
dust I'll rise she may be best known for
her work on the British soap opera
EastEnders and was recently seen in Ella
Henderson's music video for her song
Brave
everything
[Music]
following the news of her death fans
flooded the comments of her most recent
Instagram post with messages like R.I.P
Josephine and thank you for all the
great work you have done
I mean this is but
[Music]
let's not worry about that because
I'm sure I'm sure